this video is made possible by audible
with an unmatched selection of
audiobooks original audio shows news
comedy and more get a free audio book of
your choice with a 30-day free trial at
audible.com slash second thought
in a past video we explored gamma-ray
bursts as a potential explanation for
the Fermi paradox for a more thorough
overview of the paradox as a whole click
the link on your screen but here's a
brief refresher one day back in 1950
physicist Enrico Fermi was having lunch
with some friends discussing the
possibility of intelligent civilizations
elsewhere in the universe when he
stopped and thought where is everybody
Fermi realized that given the extent of
what humanity had achieved in its short
existence compared to the age of the
rest of the universe there should be far
older and more advanced species out
there somewhere he speculated that any
civilization was sufficiently advanced
space travel technology could spread out
and populate their entire galaxy within
ten million years while that may sound
like a long time the age of our own
galaxy is about 10,000 times that
meaning colonizing the Milky Way would
be a fairly quick endeavor on a
cosmological timescale so if there has
been plenty of time for alien
civilizations to populate the universe
where are they over the course of the
past half century there have been dozens
of papers written addressing the Fermi
paradox some offering plausible
solutions and others claiming there's no
paradox at all there simply aren't any
aliens one proposed solution is that at
some point in any advanced civilizations
development all life forms get wiped out
they simply reach a barrier that no life
has yet been able to pass this is called
the great filter and it offers a fairly
plausible explanation for the Fermi
paradox the premise of the great filter
hypothesis is that intelligent beings
never make it very far along the
Kardashev scale before they hit a wall
this wall could be disease asteroid
impacts nuclear war or the development
of some new and unstable technology that
destroys all life among other
possibilities according to the
hypothesis this happens all the time
life evolves to roughly the
technological level of current day earth
and then goes extinct before it can make
contact with other civilizations the
scary thing about the great filter is we
don't know where it is on our timeline
have we already passed it making us the
first-ever civilization to survive or
does it still loom ahead
meaning Humanity is closer to the end
than the beginning or perhaps there are
several filters the first being the
appearance of single-celled life then
the jump to more complex life forms and
so on
let's look at a few explanations for why
we're still here and seem to be all
alone in the universe
first and most hopefully we've already
made it past the great filter this is a
very arrogant stance to take if
literally every single life form before
us has failed and gone extinct but the
possibility is there that we earthlings
are special and somehow cleverly evaded
our mass extinction event that event
could have been the jump from semi
intelligent animals to fully sentient
hominids a near-miss of a giant asteroid
the avoidance of nuclear destruction
during the Cold War or any number of
other possibilities but what if that's
not the case what if we haven't made it
past the filter that brings us to
possibility number two the great filter
is still ahead of us but we are one of
if not the very first life-forms to have
a chance of making it through for those
of us who don't think Humanity is quite
special enough to have already
successfully navigated the great filter
but would still very much like the human
race to survive this is the viewpoint
for you perhaps the great filter was
stricter in the past and only recently
have conditions in the universe become
agreeable enough that life can continue
into its more advanced stages maybe the
human race is just in the right go
lactic neighborhood at the right time to
become the first super advanced
interplanetary species or maybe not the
final possibility is that the great
filter is still ahead of us but there's
nothing we can do to save ourselves from
extinction unfortunately many proponents
of the great filter hypothesis speculate
that this is the most likely possibility
being in the right place at the right
time with just the right conditions to
become the very first life-forms to
survive the great filter seems absurdly
unlikely which leaves us with the
unpleasant and very real possibility
that humans are living on borrowed time
we're certainly doing the best we can to
establish our own man-made great filters
runaway climate change antibiotic
resistant superbugs multiple nations
with their fingers poised over the big
red button we seem to have the odds
stacked against us before we even
consider the possibilities of asteroid
impacts gamma-ray bursts or some yet
unknown Cataclysm but who knows maybe we
are special maybe humanity does exist in
the perfect pocket of time and space to
make it past this great filter just
maybe we're more significant than we
give ourselves credit
if this topic sounds interesting to you
I highly recommend you check out the
Copernicus complex for free on audible I
have a multi-day road trip coming up
next month and you better believe I'll
be passing the time listening to books
like the Copernicus complex and contact
with audible audible is a great way to
learn about fascinating subjects or just
listen to your favorite books on the go
and unlike streaming or rental services
your books on audible are yours forever
you can download and listen to great
books on just about any device and if it
turns out you don't like a book you
chose swap it out with audibles great
listen guarantee sign up for your 30 day
free trial at audible.com slash second
thought and get a book of your choice
100% free last week I recommended 2001 a
Space Odyssey let me know in the
comments below if you've already
finished it and share your thoughts or
if nonfiction is more your style check
out cosmos by Carl Sagan visit
audible.com slash second thought to
start your free trial today if you
enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe and click the little bell to
join the notification squad you can
watch my other space related videos by
clicking here or if you're in the mood
for something a little different come
watch me play games with a friend on my
new gaming channel thanks for watching
and I'll see you in the next video